in terms of keeping the brand happy how
much checking in do they do because
you're still beholden to them you know
it's still almost it's like an employer
basically so how do I mean they're
giving you the money right pretty much
and I've always in my life I've always
said like whoever's giving you the money
you need to be giving them attention
first like take their phone calls sorry
because that's it you know you have a
responsibility I've always felt like I
have a you know a moral ethical
responsibility to you know at the end of
the day right and so did you see me I
know you came in when stuff was already
established but did you see a lot of
checking in notes back because I can
imagine they would have some creative
input yeah sort of like oh maybe you're
doing too much poking at the brand or
you're not doing enough or this for that
I mean I I don't know if we were just
incredibly lucky with with the brand
that we're working with but they barely
had any notes ever Wow yeah I mean the
thing is is the team that they put
together is you know Jamie widows and
tim o'donnell is this amazing writer and
they have such a track record that
they've pretty much said you know we
trust you they're only notes were were
how the actual food was displayed you
know in in the show and we would always
wit they had a food stylist that would
be on set oh that's great and we would
always make sure that that it was taken
care of you know that was as much as
they would get the rest of it the
creative you know they trusted Jamie and
Tim and and you know to this point yeah
they're doing a season we're doing a
season four so it's definitely the trust
has been well well worth it and I think
that I mean I don't know if that's sort
of a fantasy land that I live in because
i worked with such a great brand and on
those shows but I think that's the sort
of my message to bryant's it's like you
can't start getting too involved in you
know getting in the way of the creative
you have you've gotta get with a team
that you believe in and that you think
is going to make it work and let them do
their work and at the end of the day
that's the way you're going to get the
most success
you